[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at sonos i've talked about
this for a while because sonos is
something that i've had for years and i
didn't need us i didn't need them as my
sponsor to talk about how great they
were i spent money on sonos for years
because i just love the product
anybody i know who has sonos loves this
stuff it's great for the holidays great
for gifts
i i could play music in each room of my
house or i could play party mode
in all the rooms at the same time or you
know outside could be party mode inside
could be just chill with my yacht rock
music you could do anything sonos is
affordable it's light you don't need big
receivers and all these other things
um sonos makes it so easy so share the
joy of listening on sonos this season
make the sound system on your wish list
a reality with speakers and sound bars
that are easy to set up i mean they're
easy dude i can freaking do it they're
easy to use they all work together so
you can listen in any or every room like
i talked about and bring the family
together with some incredible sound
forever from everything for from classic
carols to festive films sonos works with
all your streaming services and control
is simple with the sonos app your voice
using amazon alexa or google assistant
and apple airplay 2 spoil the listeners
in your life with a gift that keeps on
giving treat gamers and movie lovers to
an immersive home theater experience
with beam that's b-e-a-m keep your
fitness loving friends motivated with
great sound for their workout playlists
with move and help relatives relax with
hand-free control of their music and
more on sonos one
i mean why isn't sonos on your holiday
wish list
you just don't know don't you well it's
time it's time to get some sonos during
the holidays and you can go to my
friendly friends over at sonos.com to
learn more and wrap up your holiday
shopping at sonos.com
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum thanks for joining me
if you're sitting in your car you're on
your way to work i hope you have a great
day at work i hope you have a great week
at work i hope you're listening and
you're enjoying and
you know take your mind off things for a
minute got a great guest today greg
sulkin
um
the runaway is pretty smart uh you know
we'll get into that in a minute um talks
about selena gomez working with her and
having a healthy lifestyle ryan i had a
little uh little little issue this last
week what happened well we went on a
post thanksgiving hike uh-huh and i take
my friends out to victorville and we go
on this hike and it's a bunch of us
that's far and my friend christy it is
kind of far but it's a great time we
drive out a couple hours we hike in an
hour we're down to these hot springs so
we get down there and it's a little
treacherous to get through we have to
get through waist-deep water to get to
these natural hot springs
well i get across everybody's across
except my girlfriends
christy and shira and they're just you
know i think they're [ __ ] around so
i'm like guys come on i'm yelling across
the water come on it's great over here
and they're like we're gonna go back and
i'm like what
and uh i looked at the other guys my
friends who are in the hot springs i go
uh something's wrong i gotta i gotta go
back and i walked back and christy's
face
was just swollen like i mean i've never
like like rocky balboa 12th round
and like just a huge golf ball on her
face i'm like oh my god what happened so
she slipped on a rock and hit her face
so we immediately had to turn around
right when we got there turn around and
hike back up but she was a good sport
she's doing okay but it was kind of
crazy because if she would have split
that open or something it could have
been a lot
worse but we ended up going to the olive
garden after and regardless we were very
happy about the olive garden taking care
of us at victorville thank you olive
garden and uh christy was a really good
sport so christy if you're listening um
you're a good sport you didn't ruin the
trip at all but it was uh
you go into survival mode like okay uh
here's what we're gonna do and then she
was okay but we had to hustle back and
it was a hard treacherous hike back
so i was i was definitely a little
worried um hey thanks for listening as i
said uh
also i want to just throw a shout out
at my buddies at the company
weird yeah it's weird w-y-r-d weird
leatherandmede.com
uh they have amazing stuff over there
weird is a nerdy medieval fantasy pop
culture loving business uh that is
heavily focused around the community and
recently played host to the rose city
comic con launch party for more
information check it out because they've
got this wonderful mead if you haven't
had meat it's like a what would you call
it like a
it's uh it's a sweet it's uh
what is it it's fermented
i don't know how to describe it well
it's the oldest alcoholic beverage in
the world
and
meat is brewed using honey as it's sugar
source instead of grapes it's delicious
they sent me a bunch of this stuff
all you have to do if you want to check
this out and support small businesses is
go to
weirdleatherandme.com and become a
warrior of the weird and weird is
w-y-r-d leather and mead weird lettering
mead.com also a shout out to echoes of
hope who i work with
you can donate to them they're hosting a
holiday event for under resourced
children teens and young adults roughly
300 students will be supported this
december
and so if you want to purchase a gift
you just go to echoesofhope.org
uh tell them i sent you it'd be it's the
holidays so you want to give back echoes
ech oes echoesofhope.org
great and last but not least is another
company that i'm i'm working with a
non-profit another nonprofit called food
on foot if you go to foodonfoot.org you
can help the homeless situation which is
getting bigger and bigger and we need to
put a stop to it so if you want to
donate for the holidays
it's a great great uh great place
they do so much for the homeless
community and you go to
foodonfoot.org to help them out so
echoesofhope.org
foodonfoot.org and weird
leatherandme.com these are just some
places i thought i'd shout out
um if you want to follow us our handles
are at insideypodcast on the uh
instagram and facebook and insideyoupod
on the twitter um anything else ryan you
want to add to that
you got nothing
we got new stuff at the inside evil
online store new tumblers so check out
the inside of you online store and some
great stuff at the sunspin my band
sunspin.com and you could book us for a
zoom
if you go to
sunspin.com i don't sell those those are
little stress balls that i give for all
my patrons and speaking of patreon if
you go to patreon.com inside of you i
know there's a lot today but you know
it's the holidays
but my patrons really support the
podcast in so many ways more ways than
you could possibly imagine and i'm very
grateful to them and uh some of them uh
depending on what tier you're in you get
a package from me every couple of months
and a note from me and uh and as ryan
was saying these little stress balls
those are one of the gifts that i throw
in one of the boxes so uh go to uh
patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash
inside of you patreon dot com slash
inside of you and join patreon today
join the family so many people become
friends on that it's a wonderful
community and i thank them a million but
let's
you know i think we have a we have a
busy day today um greg sulkin is on the
podcast it was great i didn't know him
at all and when i don't know someone
it's uh
i learn a [ __ ] ton i really learn a lot
and you think okay was this guy going to
bring anything and he brought it and i
think you're going to really enjoy him
he's a lot of fun and i think you'll
learn a little from him
we talk a lot about a lot of good stuff
and
thanks for supporting me you know
sometimes you don't know the guest
but you listen anyway and you learn
something and uh
so many emails that you guys send me
that uh
you know they tell me how the podcast
affects you and it means a [ __ ] ton to
me
so that's awesome
so ryan that's it ryan brought me a gift
he brought me a bottle of wine i
appreciate that for the holidays i don't
get gifts very often but it was very
nice of you to bring me a gift and
there's a little hanukkah present it's a
hanukkah president it's the fourth day
of hanukkah i'm not a real practicing
jew but uh you know i'm i'm proud to say
that i am jewish and uh
i don't care what you are i'm proud of
you
and you should be proud of that and
respect
everyone we love you uh let's get inside
of greg sulkin it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience i i thought about this i
thought about before doing the podcast
today i was like you know he's too good
we i mean i've seen these interviews
you know you've done a lot of great work
and all this stuff but i'm like there's
got to be some dark side to him there's
got to be something because i know that
you want to play
and you can play
the bad guy you want to be perceived
probably as the bad guy because like for
me i was always a goof and then and then
they gave me the chance to be lex luthor
and everybody all my friends were like
you lex luthor this is ridiculous
but like i'd love to see you as like the
uh the christian bale in american psycho
or something like that where you're just
such a great guy but then you you
uncover the darkness
there's got to be some [ __ ] i mean
i'm i'm i'm a gemini so i like you i
date geminis really yeah yeah a bit bit
nuts
uh are they a bit nice i think so
they say there's two sides to gemini's
and i agree so i definitely think that
yeah maybe in my career i've only been
able to show like one side maybe
not one side but you know a few
different sides but the the dark side
right is definitely a fun side that one
day i'd like to well how old are you i'm
29 29 yeah
do you feel like you've lived or you
feel like you you have so much to to do
i feel like i have so much to do and
achieve for sure because i've always
been very driven right very like i feel
like i got that from my dad my dad grew
up with nothing
um
and worked his ass off and and provided
for me and my brother and my mom and you
know come from a very like traditional
household right
um so i definitely got the hard-working
gene i think from him
um
but then on the other side it's like
yeah you can i feel like i've been going
through this over the last years like
especially through the pandemic you sort
of question what's important and yeah
working is really important and
achieving success
to me is really important but at the
same time it is important just to sort
of breathe for a second take in your
friendships enjoy those moments with
your mates
go for a glass of wine and just shoot
the [ __ ] you know like yeah be present
yeah and i think that's it's really hard
for me in this industry because i'm
always thinking of the next job or how
can we further the career or
what what can we do what can i be doing
to be better and sometimes that's not
always the healthiest why is it ryan
that i feel like you know once again
there's a there's a 20 year old
nine-year-old man here in the room and
i'm 49 and yet i feel like he's got it
taken care of he's got a good head on
his shoulders and i need i'm going to
learn something from him that's what i
already get that and he said 10 words
you probably will learn something
because what a good day for you because
i wasn't thinking about being present
i'm just i'm trying to learn that now
is being present being what let's let's
take it back let's go back to like when
you were growing up i mean so you were
your mother and father always very
present always were they like greg i
love you i'm proud of you i i i just
whatever you want to do son was it
always like that my mom was uh
my dad i love he sacrificed so much you
know i used to play soccer as a kid and
he used to give up his job and not give
up his job but used to leave his job
early to take me to soccer and so
there's hours and days and and months
that he's sacrificed but at the same
time he was a little bit hard on me in
the sense of
i remember playing soccer and he used to
look at me from across the field if i
did a bad pass and i wasn't worried
about what the coaches said i was just
more worried about what my dad said
just the look that he gave you just the
look and i could see it from a far away
and i could see his body language
throughout the game
so yeah he's been definitely like tough
but i think it came from a place of like
love like
don't sell yourself short like i know
what you're capable of
whether it's acting whether it's
as a human being you know like we could
all be doing more and so like don't sell
yourself short was the mentality that he
had towards me so he wasn't always like
like your mom was like i love you
sweetheart he was just a little tougher
on you little i got i got you beat
though it's not this isn't a contest but
i remember my dad i told the story
before i think but did i tell you the
story about after i scored three goals
in a hockey game and we won the game and
we went on to the finals in the
tournament my dad was the head coach
and i remember being in the car going i
go dad i scored two goals and then i
scored the winning goal in overtime and
we won and my dad just goes it was a
week goalie oh that's not ideal he was
he was he was really tough on me he was
really hard on me and he wasn't someone
i think it was just like the the era
that he lived in you know he couldn't he
couldn't say i love you i'm proud of you
it wasn't in the cards he wanted me i
think inadvertently to feel like he was
a superhero like he was like he never
drank he never smoked he never did this
and then i learned as i got older that
he did all this [ __ ] and he was a [ __ ]
up too he was a big [ __ ] up he probably
invented acid
you know what i mean how old is he he's
about 19 years older than me so well
he's 16 he's uh 70 and i'll be 50. next
year okay so similar my my dad had me a
little bit late too and um
they're the same age so that makes total
sense from that era of like that tough
love were you were they tougher was he
tougher on you than you was your brother
um my brother
ugh i don't know my brother i love i
love my brother he
no they're they're they were tough on us
in different ways for sure like how my
my brother
does real estate my dad does real estate
so i think that there's a lot of like
this is what you should be doing whereas
like in this field like they don't
really know
what to say to you so i get off a little
lightly but i think with my brother
um
yeah like i think they're just they're
tough they want us to do well they want
us to be kind they want us to you know
um push forward our life and if we're
not doing that then
you know then they're not then
especially my dad he's not thrilled
because my dad sacrificed everything you
know it's like it's not
easy to wake up at three four o'clock in
the morning my dad sold like um
kitchenware on the street corners wow
it's sort of like how he you know he got
expelled at 13 years old from school was
involved in fighting um
and involved in fighting meaning he
started the fight and finished it
exactly
um but you know he just
left school at 13 14
um
and then hustled himself just sort of
him and his brother and then they sold
kitchenware and then they ended up doing
real estate and then they were known in
london as like these two young property
guys who sort of came from nowhere so
like i have a lot of respect for that
because i think it's
hard to to to to you know create success
on your own without help um and he
managed to do that well what did he
think about you when you started
thinking you know he's busted his ass
he's selling you know heart what is it
again what was he selling kitchenware
kitchenware kitchen kitchenware i mean
kitchen farberware and things like
whatever those
yeah yeah like things that you know you
you you cutlery yeah yeah cutlery
cutlery cutlery but also machines like
how to slice an avocado or
you know what i mean the wonder knife it
would just simply cut through anything
yeah he was a great salesman like he
i've seen videos he just
he just knew what he was doing he knew
how to sell maybe you got some of that
salesmanship from him in terms because
acting is kind of salesmanship you're
selling yourself right yeah i mean
you're selling your soul just selling
your soul
uh yeah yeah i mean yeah there's a
presentation aspect for sure right that
i think i got from him well i hope i got
from him well do you think that you know
it was hard when you were i don't know
how old you were you could tell me but
like getting into acting when he's been
doing all this stuff and busting his ass
and then you're like i want to be an
actor
yes i mean i got into acting when i was
12 or 13. so for me was it high school
or a grade school
we don't we do like what is junior
school and senior school junior school
see what's junior school go up to oh i
think maybe like eighth grade 12 i don't
know what that is right oh sorry you
wouldn't know that yeah exactly so i'm
telling him something he wouldn't know
junior school because we have grade
school we have junior school middle
school and then we have high school
right so it's like first through sixth
grade and you're about up till about 11
and then 12 and 13 years old for middle
school and then 14 to 18 for for high
school yeah we have
no no no no junior school and senior
school and i don't remember the school
wasn't really a thing for me i mean i
enjoyed it i enjoyed it for the social
aspect and i enjoyed it for the sports
but the academic side of school is not
for me so what were you in in high
school were you popular
i mean popular it was actually pretty
weird because i i felt like i got on
with everybody and then when i got into
the industry i got treated differently
when i came back
um because i went to the same school as
freddie highmore who's a very successful
actor um
i looked at you blankly didn't i
no no no no
i mean a little bit but he's done a lot
of big stuff for sure like freddie the
charlie and the chocolate factory yeah
he debates motel he's now oh okay now i
know exactly who he is you know who he
is the good doctor good dog yeah
yes so you went to school with him yeah
but the thing is with freddie and the
difference between freddie and i was
freddie was extremely intelligent um and
was all in the a don't say yourself
short and i was uh just not in the a set
you know and so when freddie went away
to to shoot
i asked the same question like oh hey
i've got this job can i go away to shoot
and they were like
no and freddie was allowed to just
because he was so incredibly intelligent
right um that he was able to do both
whereas it took me a minute to
to
do film and tv and also study
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at better help better help
online therapy
boy i can't tell you how much this works
i get emails all the time thank you for
talking about better help thank you for
getting me into to therapy
ryan does better help i do
i just you know uh i just had a friend
this morning i was facetiming with him
and his wife said you know my kid's uh
dealing with depression
and uh do you know any good therapists i
go better help online therapy because
they're in the middle of sort of nowhere
and you don't need to go anywhere you
can facetime or text or you know it's
it's better help is just uh it's amazing
it's it's helped you out yeah it's uh
it's convenient
yeah it has been good i have gotten a
lot out of it well i like that look
whether you're struggling with grief
relationships or stress or having
trouble sleeping or meeting goals online
therapy might be for you better help is
secure online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with a
licensed professional
therapists betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
accredited therapist you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room therapists
have a broad range of expertise which
may not be available in your area
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime folks
send a message to your therapist you'll
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
you need and that may happen you know
you meet someone the first time you may
not vibe with him he changed the
therapist better help it's that easy
and i i completely recommend this
so many people have told me it works
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy by a landslide if you
ask me and financial aid is available
visit betterhelp.com
inside and join over the 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help ryan
that they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states
inside of you is sponsored by better
help and our listeners get 10 off their
first month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's better betterhelp.com
inside give it a shot
better help inside of you is brought to
you by hellofresh
hello fresh say that ryan hello fresh
hello fresh doesn't it just sounds soft
and supple and sweet when you say hello
fresh fresh fresh is a good word yeah
with hellofresh guys you get fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
and guess what you skip those trips to
the grocery store
and you count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it is america america's
number one
meal kit hello fresh meals are ready in
around 30 minutes or less plus with
their quick and easy meals 20 minute
recipes or low prep and easy clean up
options you can get food on the table
quicker so you can spend more holiday
time with loved ones save an average
over 65 dollars per month when you order
hellofresh instead of grocery shopping
that's more money to spend on presents
and activities what i love about this is
that i'm getting a good meal a solid
meal that i can choose that is easy to
put together and make i'm not ordering
on these you know these apps where you
spend tons and tons of money for
delivery fees and all these things
i spend so much money on that stuff and
it's like you get this stuff it's
cheaper than going to the grocery store
and it's all there
portioned out for you so you don't have
to you won't make mistakes i i make this
stuff
i make wonderful dinners
and i'm proud of it and it looks easy
because it is easy go to hellofresh.com
iou14
and use code iou14 for up to 14 free
meals and three free gifts
that's hellofresh.com slash iou14 and
use code iou14 for up to 14 free meals
and three
free
gifts pretty incredible america's number
one meal kit hellofresh go check it out
inside of you is brought to you by
brooke linen i love these guys at brook
london they know comfort they just sent
me a whole bunch of sheets i put them on
my bed i'm sleeping longer i'm more
comfortable and boy
are these sheets effective
i i gotta tell you
i
i'm used to just like you think you just
need cheap sheets on a bed no
you can have quality but you can have
quality affordable sheets on your bed
and it just makes such a difference i
didn't realize that thank you brooke
linden
if the holidays snuck up on you too no
there's still time to get it right this
gifting season brooklyn has perfect
presents for everyone on your list
whether you're shopping cents for a
candle lover or grabbing a gift card aka
the gift that keeps on giving this kind
of comfort is always a hit for the
holiday brooklyn makes award-winning
comfort year-round that makes the
perfect gift this holiday season
brooklyn's goal is to create beautiful
high quality home essentials that don't
break the bank it's the perfect place to
find the best gift take the guess work
out of gifting with comfy crowd pleasers
from brooklyn you got to give brooklyn
in a shot you got to check them out you
know people always email me they're like
hey seriously what products do you
really like and brooklyn's one of the
products that when they send me when
they send you product to try out
that's when you know if you really like
it and then you can actually talk about
it and say friends brooklyn is the real
deal they're great i would i would
definitely recommend them to anybody
give the gift of comfort this season
this holiday season and save while you
do it go to brookelinen.com and use
promo code inside for twenty dollars off
with a minimum purchase of one hundred
dollars that's brooklyn and b-r-o-o-k-l
dot com and enter the promo code inside
for twenty dollars off with a minimum
purchase of one hundred dollars
brookelinen.com promo code inside
what was the first thing you did at 12
years old i did a movie called 66. 66.
was that the one with helena bonham
carter it was
you see how i know my [ __ ] it was have
you seen the movie i haven't seen it but
i love helena bonham carter okay so was
she intimidating
no she wasn't no she was the nicest
human ever because it was very weird it
was actually my first audition my dad
told me hey
you know
no it was actually my mom she showed me
a newspaper article and i'm jewish
i'm a jew too
um
and so
and so you know uh my mom saw a
newspaper article and it said oh
auditioning for a a boy who's just
recently had his bar mitzvah
and it's to play
in a movie a universal movie
uh called 66. this was the first thing
you auditioned for the first thing i
ever auditioned for oh my god and it was
crazy i i my mom said to me she was like
look if you i was like no don't be
ridiculous i don't want to act like this
is absurd like i'm not doing it and she
was like well if you do it i never asked
you to do anything again just go to the
audition so i was like okay great at 12
years old i was like 13 i was like
perfect i don't have to
you know don't have to listen to my mom
telling me what to do like sign me up i
went there fiona where was the casting
director who casted harry potter wow um
and it ended up just sort of working out
and then helena came onto the movie it
was richard curtis who wrote the movie
and it was just like this big movie in
the uk and i was this kid who'd never
done anything before never wanted to do
anything before and then somehow got
like an opportunity of a lifetime to go
and be in a
movie the lead
um
with helena playing my mom and eddie
marsden too who's unbelievable and you
didn't know honestly did you have an
acting coach did you you did you didn't
know what you were doing didn't even
know acting characters existed to be
honest you just got in there learned
your lines and started acting yeah
that's absurd i know it is now thinking
about it i'm like
what was i doing and i didn't know what
i was doing maybe you were just fearless
as a kid fearless i remember the first
day i got to uh i think it was pinewood
studios in in in london
and i got there and you know on on sets
there's obviously the inside of the set
and then there's the backdrop
so we did the first three three weeks on
location and then the rest was in in a
studio we ended up
i remember going
after remember going to the set and
assuming that i just had to act in front
of the backdrop and they would just plop
me in into the scene like i had no idea
that there was a set inside in front of
the backdrop that's how much i like knew
about the industry but i loved it
because you know what what i loved about
it is what i still love about it today
which is the crew
i love working with the crew i think
it's so collaborative i think it's so
nice to be in a t i grew up playing
sports so for me it's not like oh i'm
the lead of the show or i'm the leader
of this movie it's like no like we're
all creating this movie together and
let's hope it's successful let's hope
it's a hit and that experience of
working with people who are amazing at
their job is what to me makes it so fun
you know what i like to do on set always
i've always been
because they're they're like the first
they're like the audience
to me when i'm acting um i always want
to know everyone's names i want to get
to know their names because i think you
said this in an interview before and
you're dead on right
as far as i'm concerned how they become
family
they're sort of your family while you're
there and you get to know these guys
it's almost like a support system you
can do your best work
and i noticed a lot of actors
don't know the crew's name they just hit
their mark or they're just they're sort
of oblivious it's just my lines and act
but you seem to
want to get to know these folks you want
to seem to get to know the crew and
and talk about that for sure i just
think that they are you know as an actor
it's like look the entertainment
industry isn't glamorous as you know but
in a way it's like
as an actor you do get treated so well
like you know you have people bringing
you coffee you have people making sure
that your shoes are comfortable i
brought you coffee i know i know it was
amazing thank you very very nice by the
way i made you coffee too ryan i did i
drank it yeah oh wow you did
you downed it yeah both of you i feel
like are more men than more men you're
more
like men than i am because you have your
coffee black i always under black coffee
yeah it's like i'll just have a black
coffee i'm a man i'm like i like some
sweetener like some whipped cream um i
want mine to be a little bit uh fun in
the morning
but uh you you like to get to know the
crew you like to have become family for
sure i just think that i was so you were
a kid yeah
yeah i remember i still remember the
first run as you know like a runner
person somebody gets your coffee yeah i
still know his first i don't remember i
was 13 years old and i still remember
his name was joey blond hair the coolest
dude and to be honest joey the runner
probably allowed me to have such an
amazing experience on set is one of the
reasons why i'm actually still in this
industry today because if i had a bad
experience i wouldn't have continued it
but he was just so nice and so chill
that i was like oh this is amazing like
and i haven't spoken to him since i left
the the movie but he still sticks with
me for sure joey
you've done a really good job look at
this career this guy has and it's all
because of joey
for sure and even on my last show we had
a set pa called greg who was amazing on
the current show now
there's cassie and mitch who are like
amazing so it's like yeah they do that
but they become your family and these
people you know they
they're just they're just great so hard
working and it's fun you know i think
they're really i think crew members are
really underappreciated especially from
the outside but i think once you've been
in the industry for a long time you know
that the crew are the glue to this
industry
how did your family perceive this
experience when do you remember when
your dad first watched this movie uh 66
he's jewish my mom converted to judaism
uh
because she married my dad right um so
he was really proud he was really proud
because
um you know as being jewish there's a
huge sense of community and
and pride to be jewish i know i feel
that um and so so yeah he was just
really proud but the best part was
that my
when i first went to the premiere it was
in leicester square which is like a big
you know it's a big it's a you know big
place to go and have a premiere
and my brother came with me who at the
time was 17 years old 18 years old like
very handsome boy looked like a young
david beckham at the time like long hair
wore a suit like immaculate i remember
getting out the car
and
i remember getting out the car and there
was just screaming fans like screaming
girls and they thought you know the
movie was they thought he was he was the
star and he was there signing autographs
taking my life staging it was the worst
ever it was the worst ever so you know
it's always sort of humbled me and also
borat the movie borat came out the same
day as 66 did right and so we were
expected to be a huge hit and borat sort
of became like a global you know hit and
so we didn't become the hit that we
thought that we were going to become um
which was the best thing to ever happen
to me because i think if if you if
you're 13 years old and you don't know
yourself and suddenly you become
extremely famous i don't know how
healthy that is for a human being at 13.
so i don't know how people do it i don't
know how people get such uh success at a
young age i've been working since um you
know i did a play when i was in high
school and then i did plays in college
and then i went to new york and i made
no money doing off off way the hell off
broadway and then i started doing stuff
but it was always incremental it was
always
step by step two steps back one step
forward
and it just it just kind of gradually i
never was an overnight success like the
guy on my show tom welling who was on
smallville he was sort of an overnight
success and i always looked like holy
[ __ ] man how do you deal with all that
pressure so you're saying ultimately
that the the fact that this movie wasn't
a huge success
kind of humbled you and you know got you
made you a little more prepared for what
was to come for sure 100 because as you
know there's ups and downs there's
definitely steps back or you feel their
steps back um step step back step yeah
[Music]
um
and
and so yeah you know i think it
definitely propelled me for what this
industry is all about which is you've
got to be thick-skinned uh you've got to
be able to maneuver you've got to be
able to kind of lift yourself up when
things don't go your way um and so yeah
it was the best thing to ever happen to
me were you
pleased with your performance
did he handle it helena helena
hello we say helena did hell
did helena come up to you and was like
you're so lovely you're so wonderful in
the movie i loved you terrible english
accent it was actually not bad really
yeah it was not bad at all i felt like
she was there look if i closed my eyes i
would have started talking to helen
um when she actually lived five minutes
away from
my house in well not my house my
family's house in london and she was
already with tim burton at the time she
was with tim at the time was here at the
premiere yes did you meet him i did i
actually went over to helena and tim's
house uh because they lived so close and
they after the movie they kept inviting
me over do they live in like a edward
scissorhands kind of house you know what
was really cool um
i know they're no longer together but
what i thought was really they're not i
know oh that's a drag i thought they
were the perfect couple it's just that
perfect mesh of weirdness they were
really special to me they they wrote me
as a rap gift they gave me the first
prop that you see on charlie in the
chocolate factory uh you know the poster
yeah that you see on the lamppost yeah
uh that they signed me uh they signed
that for me on the back of it and i
actually have it in my house really yeah
it's really cool do you keep stuff do
you keep stuff from sets do you keep
like memorabilia do you ever ask for
autographs because as you can see
looking in my home i get autographs i
collect things i do things because i
always feel like
i was always doing that beforehand and i
never thought i'd be famous and i never
thought i'd fit in so i thought you know
this could be my last movie this could
be my last show every time i do
something so i'm like i'll get an
autograph i'll have it i'll have
memorabilia one day i'll show my kids if
i have it or my friend's kids or
whatever and i thought it'd be cool do
you get stuff like that do you keep
things i'm exactly the same as you in
the sense of like you know i don't keep
as much as what you get to be honest
this is like a little
insane but i think what i do i always
try to take the back of the cost chairs
uh i have all those yeah you know it's
just it says it says the project it says
your name yeah you have it do you also
have a chair yeah i'm sure you have one
shoe i don't actually have a chair i
don't have a chair i just have the backs
of them do you want to hear something
cool this is a big name drop in my
office
so i was friends with the late carrie
fisher she was a good friend of mine and
i loved her dearly and uh i miss her but
um one day i came over to the house her
house and she goes uh take that chair i
go
it was her carrie fisher uh chair from
um star wars a force awakens it's a
carrie fisher force awakens and i go
okay where do you want me to take it she
goes home i don't want it i know you
love this [ __ ]
so i have carrie fisher's cast chair
that's in my office
that's so isn't that cool that's awesome
i always feel like billy her daughter's
gonna call me one day and say can i have
that and i'd say probably yeah yeah yeah
i think you'd probably have to give that
back but it's so that's so cool because
you also think about
that chair is not just a chair obviously
like the memories of
you know carrie fisher being in that car
chair during during that shoot like
that's what it probably brings back so i
mean yeah and also her just saying it's
yours take it it was just meaningful she
just knew that yes it's for her it's
whatever but for me she knows i'm a huge
star wars fan and i always kept my cool
around her i never really asked for
stuff
i just you know i was always a friend
and then she
she just gave me the cast chair that's
awesome well i'm sorry i didn't bring
anything here you know yeah what the
hell yeah sorry what have you kept um i
have i just keep the back of the car
shares and i get the script signed um on
the front of the the front by the entire
account the cast and the crew i always
say the cast are on the the front right
and then the crew's all in the the
script
really yeah so it's cool because you
know what's amazing is
the crew have made this experience the
crew have made my experience in this
industry amazing because i look back on
it and i'm just like oh i remember that
person oh that was so chill there's
private jokes in there too
um you know between you know me and that
individual person so it's just it's just
nice it's like a yearbook right it is it
is like a yearbook
um
was your mom
right after you did this movie you're
like
i told you to do this i said she should
do it she still she still says it she's
all because of me she kind of says like
subtly and politely but obviously not
very subtly because i pick up on it
every time but she's always like you
know like i was the one to tell you to
go to america like because she was uh
she was the one to tell me to go to the
audition so her instinct has been right
like she her instinct
she knew you had something
yeah but i think every mum feels like
this
that child has something not my mom
really no no no she didn't think i had
anything really yeah i think i i think
she called me dummy once
uh maybe a few times but she was well no
not ideal but i never felt like
i've got something until i remember i
did a play in college and they saw my
play
he gets it for me
he gets it from me
you know she wants to take all the
credit for it yeah of course so what was
it after so you were you were hooked
after this because you had such an
amazing experience with joey yeah joey
the the the runner the runner and the
whole cast and the crew and you had such
a great time in the premiere
and you said i want to continue this
yeah i just also i didn't love school so
i was like oh wow i get to miss school
like that's awesome like but don't you
get homeschooled or whatever it is yeah
on set right schooled to be honest you
do get set scored but i remember our
first my first ever tutor her name was
catherine and i used to hide from her a
lot um and we you know a lot like and
she literally said to my mom at some
stage she's like you know this is
becoming illegal you know he's not doing
he's not learning he's not doing enough
hours
um but that that was my school um
and yeah so after so after that i went
back to school got treated definitely
different uh kids kids yeah look were
you picked on
you know it's
i guess people have different
ways of putting it you know some people
may
i see i don't know like
i i yeah i guess it doesn't seem like it
was a good experience when you went back
to school it wasn't it wasn't the best
experience but you know what like i've
always thought that if someone's gonna
like pick on you like
it's it's a highlight on them not me
right you know like i remember coming
back a couple of times and
they used to get my school bag and like
dump out the books you know just trying
to be funny and i didn't really i
honestly didn't really care because i
was just like you know what
i don't think a lot of people have this
mentality in in in school because you
know you feel like oh my god it's
forever and your high school friends are
your friends forever and the reality is
like in my mind i was like
well i'm only here for a couple of more
years like i'm never going to really see
these people again if they want to dump
my books out because
at the end of the day like they're kind
of
annoyed or somewhat um jealous of the
fact that another student of theirs i.e
me is going off and doing something that
they're not you know then like it's a
highlight on there did you really have
that mentality so at that young age
where we could easily be picked apart
and fall apart
you had the well with all well with
where would all where with all thank you
that's why i have ryan here the
wherewithal
to to know
that this will subside this will go away
this is just a moment in time they're
maybe jealous whatever reasons it's on
them this isn't on me let's just get
through this yeah that's amazing yeah i
don't know why i just was always very
calm i just i remember like looking at
my books and being like this is like
pathetic on them you know not me it's
like takes five seconds to pick it up
like i'm not gonna spend any energy
really thinking about you know them
dumping out my my books didn't really
care you know i i i had the wherewithal
uh as well as a child really yes i
remember um some kids were in the garage
and they were all sniffing gas
and um i grew up in a small town in
indiana this is what people did uh and
they were saline right gasoline they're
sniffing gasoline and doing things that
you know and i remember just
backtracking like walking backwards out
of the garage
and then just like slowly turning a
corner and walking back home cutting
through all the backyards back to my
house thinking
i shouldn't be here right now
something told me
because i could have easily that those
kids were doing it peer pressure and
like you know
and i looked back and i stopped hanging
out with those kids and two of them went
to prison
and i wonder what it would have been
like if i just didn't have that and i
just felt like you know i want to belong
because we always want to
feel like we belong and you know you do
something because oh that kid's doing
and that kid's doing it and i don't want
to feel like the odd man out but i guess
i did too in a way where i like like you
i just go you know what this is gonna
this is gonna go away i i don't i don't
belong here this isn't this isn't the
place for me yeah i guess there is there
is that little voice inside of your head
saying like you know what yeah this
isn't for me because what you just said
is somewhat true to in my life too there
was a kid
who is kind of i just nothing it wasn't
the connection just wasn't there there
was something off and he also ended up
in in jail i'm not saying that obviously
people end up in jail uh
uh bad people at all i just personally
don't want to end up in jail and i think
right you know like but i do think that
people can come out of it you know a few
of my dad's friends have been in jail
and come out of it change their life
around like sure you know it's not like
it's not that's it your life's over but
yeah it's an area that i want to avoid
for sure but i also think
yeah but i also think
you know even with drugs i think for
that was the same for me with drugs i
you never got into it
never have you ever done a drug
so you've never done
cocaine
obviously not heroin why would you go to
the worst one of all and why would you
jump from nothing to heroin
but
occasionally you have a drink yeah i
have it i mean it's socially acceptable
to drink from the womb in london you
know so like but you're smart boy like
you kept your head on your head straight
yeah i mean you know i just i don't know
i think like you said about your dad
earlier saying that i don't drink i
don't do drugs that was sort of i
remember i was like nine years old i
went to the kitchen my mom showed me a
newspaper article of this my mom
obviously loves newspapers um she
she showed me a newspaper article of
this woman who didn't have a middle part
of her nostril
and because she had snorted like so much
cocaine oh my god and i was just so
afraid that that was gonna happen to me
and then i you know as you grow up you
sort of especially in la you kind of
always around it whether you know it or
not you know and i was at a friend's
house the other day a woman's nose is
bleeding you know from from doing too
much cocaine it's just like it's an area
that i've always just wanted to again
avoid i also feel like i have quite an
addictive personality
so i don't want to try it because then i
have a feeling that i'll like it and
then i i want to
have a vision of where i want my life to
go and i feel like if i start involving
substances in that it may deter off that
so you know yeah not to judge people who
do it you know because some people oh no
judge them they're doing they're not
they shouldn't be doing it yeah i died
but it's it's not for me everything's in
moderation for me you know i i think
i've experimented and things like that
but it just never you know like i
remember doing coke and i was just like
i couldn't breathe the next day my
sinuses were a mess i was like yeah you
know i didn't really have fun doing that
i don't know i can't breathe the next
day uh and i don't you know for me it
was weird because i have like you know
my energy a little add so when i did
coke it kind of mellowed me a little bit
it kind of slowed me down it was the
opposite effect where people would be
all amped up and stuff but it's an ugly
drug i mean to you know think about you
know people powdering their nose and now
it's almost like even though it was a
terrible tragedy that happened where
someone
was snorting coke and there was fentanyl
in it you heard about that in hollywood
and some people died yeah well hopefully
that will instill some fear in the youth
where people will
avoid avoid that
you know that you hope that's out of
some tragedy that it has some good
effects but yeah i don't know actually
no not preaching but no it's actually my
friend's brother who that that happened
to only recently because it's definitely
going around in la so i'm actually going
to vegas in a couple of weeks and i've
already told all the boys like they know
i'm not really like
you know in that world but i've sort of
given them a heads up as a friend like
yo just so you know like i know you guys
want to have like fun but just know that
that's not you don't know what's in that
you really don't know what's in that you
know every single person you speak to
when they say like oh no no my dealer
like no trust me this is like good stuff
i'm not the truth in mind no no i trust
dan
i trust dan
dan gets the good drugs there's not
gonna be any fentanyl on the coke the ex
the mollys are gonna be clean yeah it's
[ __ ] what are you talking about yeah
like how do you know how does anyone
know
inside of you
is brought to you by geico
ryan our good friends at geico geico
geico
i mean everybody knows the name geico
folks and look you want to make life
easy on yourselves you want to not have
to be paying your auto insurance and
your homeowners insurance and your
renters and whatever it is there's all
these things that you could pay to
different companies or you could just do
what ryan you can bundle it up into one
cozy little bundle one bundle policy
with geico it's so easy it's a good
thing too because look we're busy as
hell guys we've got a lot to do around
the house geico makes it easy you just
go to geico.com
and they will bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance along with your auto
policy and they're going to give you a
great deal you know that go to geico.com
you get a quote you see how much you
could save it's geico easy visit
kycode.com
today that's
geico.com even a rosenbomb can do it
inside of you is brought to you by m1
finance you know there's a reason they
call m1 finance the finance super app
this all-in-one app makes it easy as pie
to invest borrow and spend exactly how
you want build a portfolio of stocks or
etfs in minutes with their intuitive
pies interface or use a pre-built expert
pie that invests according to your goals
investing involves risk and m1 helps you
invest according to your risk tolerance
borrow against your portfolio with some
of the lowest rates on the market then
use it however you want keep in mind
borrowing increases your risk and rates
may vary or stash your cash in their
free digital checking account it's fast
it's easy and it saves you tons of time
and time is money
switch to a sleeker easier and better
way to manage your money plus get a
thirty dollar bonus to your m1 invest
account when you get approved and funded
with one thousand dollars within your
first 14 days it's easy go to
m1finance.com
inside of you for more info that's m as
in michael the number one finance dot
com slash inside of you for more
information
that's m the number one finance.com
terms and conditions apply inside of you
is brought to you by my good friends at
sonos i've talked about this for a while
because sonos is something that i've had
for years and i didn't need us i didn't
need them as my sponsor to talk about
how great they were i spent money
on sonos for years because i just love
the product
anybody i know who has sonos loves this
stuff it's great for the holidays great
for gifts
i i could play music in each room of my
house or i could play party mode uh in
all the rooms at the same time or you
know outside could be party mode inside
could be just chill with my yacht rock
music you could do anything sonos is
affordable it's light you don't need big
receivers and all these other things
um sonos makes it so easy so share the
joy of listening on sonos this season
make the sound system on your wish list
a reality with speakers and sound bars
that are easy to set up i mean they're
easy dude i can freaking do it they're
easy to use they all work together so
you can listen in any or every room like
i talked about and bring the family
together with some incredible sound
forever from everything for from classic
carols to festive films sonos works with
all your streaming services and control
is simple with the sonos app your voice
using amazon alexa or google assistant
and apple airplay 2. spoil the listeners
in your life with a gift that keeps on
giving treat gamers and movie lovers to
an immersive home theater experience
with beam that's b-e-a-m keep your
fitness-loving friends motivated with
great sound for their workout playlists
with move and help relatives relax with
hand-free control of their music and
more on sonos one
i mean why isn't sonos on your holiday
wish list
you just don't know oh yeah well it's
time it's time to get some sonos during
the holidays and you can go to my
friendly friends over at sonos.com to
learn more and wrap up your holiday
shopping at sonos.com
uh wizards of waverly place on the
disney channel how old were you you got
that 17 17 and that ultimately changed
your life changed my life the best them
i don't know what i i mean i hope i'd
still be in the industry but it gave me
the opportunity to be in the united
states so
you know peter marietta and gary marsh
at disney channel and especially judy
taylor who sort of
had a general meeting with me in the us
when i was on holiday here
took a liking to me and then
worked so hard to create basically they
kind of created that role on wizards for
me although they
definitely didn't tell me that because
they still made me audition um
but you know they created sort of that
role for me and i'm
so grateful because it allowed me to get
my visa
um disney channel sponsored it which was
incredible
and it was just
and then to get not just get a job but
to get a job on extremely well-written
show
some would argue probably the best
disney channel show ever written in the
sense of not just people love that show
yeah and then
selena gomez obviously who's
incredible well who's that yeah exactly
yeah so she completely blew up and then
to have a storyline to play selena's
boyfriend
it was just like
one of those like wow this kind of
happened to me moments
because
she was so successful the show was the
show was becoming so popular already
already was at the time just won an emmy
so i thought it was literally the right
time right place right character right
storyline right co-star
did you have an english accent in that
in english you had an english accent but
then you started veering away from that
and a lot of projects now
like pretty smart yeah you you you do
away with that yeah you just have an
american accent yeah i think what
happened was when i first got into the
states i was you know i was obviously
practicing my dialect
and then disney channel i booked an i
booked an nbc pilot
um after i'd recovered on wizard
and
like during like after like four or five
months of being in the united states
i had booked an nbc pilot and i remember
my
the pilot
it wasn't the best pilot in the world i
would do a lot of those so my manager
who i'm still with today
good for you my manager i'm still with
uh was like okay
this i'm gonna now teach you about
leverage and so went back to disney i
went back to disney channel and said
okay he's gonna not be on the show and
at the time my character was extremely
loved and they didn't want to lose that
storyline and so disney channel put me
under a two picture deal
uh and guaranteed me i can't remember
the exact amount of episodes on the show
but that secured basically a
relationship over two years or three
years with the disney channel
which is what i wanted obviously over an
nbc pilot right um
and then one of those movies of the two
picture deal
was a movie where they said oh no you're
going to be english you're going to be
english you're going to be english we
got to new zealand
four days before we started shooting the
director came up to me and said uh his
name was stewart and goes to me hey i
think we're gonna do american for this
i'm like
wait sorry what you're gonna me do an
american accent on a worldwide platform
and i've got four days to practice this
and so obviously we did a crash course
it wasn't perfect now looking back on it
it wasn't perfect you hear yourself some
some words
of course for sure but i'm happy i did
it because it made me jump in the deep
end and terrifying
and terror yeah terrifying like just so
not natural
but now obviously doing pretty smart it
allowed me to
you know really jump into it and and
have the confidence of like okay if i
can kind of do it once then the next
time i do it i'm definitely going to be
able to like achieve it so then ever
since i just sort of went into dialect
coach and
uh you know dialect coaching and just
did it what's what are the toughest
words to do in american accent the
toughest words that you use i think
world was tough you know you guys say
world world right yeah like at first i
was like wait well i just said world
war ii
everything would be perfect except
yes i think this is an amazing world
you know that's right um bug is a tough
one burger yeah burger is a tough one
the earth the world yeah burger yeah
um
and the u sounds are tough too you know
because we we're very chewy with our
with our i speak a lot with my lips and
i'm very chewy on my words right right
because americans like you know further
back here yeah a lot more relaxed why
can't we why is it that americans can't
do english accents you guys don't need
to you guys have them you guys have the
market it's fine but you know some
people get who does the best english
accent you think president american that
you're like [ __ ] she's she or here are
really good
aren't they i don't know
i don't i don't know really i really
don't know i haven't heard too
many
i always try to think of gary oldman's
voice when i do an english accent
he he did this interview
uh when he was doing dracula and he
didn't like um francis four coppola he
wasn't getting along with francis for
copenhagen
when you're dealing in an industry like
this
you have to have a great ego
and francis ford coppola has an ego the
size of san francisco
and i've got a pretty big one too
so is that terrible no no no it's
actually i i mean it if i
if i close
if i close my eyes
i could i could buy that you could buy
it where would you say i'm from
when you're dealing in an industry like
this you've got to have a great ego
and francis full co that word was [ __ ]
i could tell you laughed at that word
when you're dealing in an industry like
this you have to have a great ego and
francis ford copeland has an eager the
size of san francisco
i would say you're from london it's
pretty neutral really yeah
you know for sure you do it cottony my
dad's cockney so he speaks a bit like
all right mate how you doing like he's a
bit like rough and ready really what
about mom mum's also a little bit the
same but she swears on
she swears a lot what's your favorite
word uh why is it that english people
could say that everything's fine my mom
does not allow me to say that word
that's one way she just one word you
can't say but yeah but the english used
the word freely like yeah we say it we
uh we do say it a lot and sometimes we
call our friends that too but your mom
doesn't like how you say it no she hates
it she won't allow me to sit really yeah
yeah she spells the letters out
it's too harsh in an american accent it
ca yeah it can be uh
like amongst so amongst a few mates of
mine they it's basically sometimes like
saying mate but i definitely think it's
in america obviously definitely not you
know it's not approved in my household
but i know in america it's not approved
either was
so you can't say that yeah what can you
say can you say [ __ ] um
my mom does i mean
in my life for sure like would
definitely say it to my mates but in my
household you really have a respect for
your mother you really try not to do you
say you swear it all around your mother
if i'm really annoyed
i would probably just you know say the f
word to be honest mom that's just [ __ ]
but i wouldn't say it to her
you know the situation's [ __ ] mommy
you're not [ __ ] i think no i swore
once or her she slapped me around the
face she slapped you yeah yeah yeah how
old were you 14 15. and you never did it
again yeah and she told me to never do
it again so i didn't what's her favorite
word
she can say anything she's you know
she's but what is the one thing you
always hear her saying if it's a swear
word [ __ ] um
no she tells me i love you she tells me
to [ __ ] off a lot she does [ __ ] off
you don't say it back how can i yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i don't i don't i don't swear it's
weird i don't really swear around my
father i don't say the f word around my
father it's weird
you know i'll say f yeah i was like
that's so f'd yeah but you lose a little
something there yeah it's not as
impactful is it no
what about selena gomez do you still
talk to her uh are you still friends for
sure still friends i always funny if i
saw her a couple of months ago and i
hadn't seen her in a couple of years and
i just said to her you know sometimes
when you're doing a show you just think
life's you know you think it's normal
and then it took me a few years to
really
i mean look i always appreciated her but
then
knowing what that that show has done for
my career
i owe everything to the writers i owe
everything to judy gary and selena was a
huge part of that because selena was the
one that if she didn't want me
on the show
she would have she would have said hey
like
find find a new boyfriend right which
they would have done in a second no but
i'm not kissing him no i think you know
and she when i went on the show that was
something that i think she really
appreciated was that i was extremely
respectful especially in kissing scenes
because
you know at the end of the day yes it's
her job to kiss her co-star but like
she's a human you know you want to
respect those boundaries too and so i
think she really respected i appreciated
the fact that i respected those
and um
just she she welcomed me she welcomed me
at the end of the day it was her show uh
all the other cast members became close
friends david henry became my best
friend i love david henry
my best brothers great guy brother great
guy jim linda his parents and uh became
my parents yeah um i had a appendectomy
when we were shooting the show and
because my mom and dad were in london
jim sorry jim linda was the first one at
the hospital
um so you know they were like my family
out here and so it wasn't just selena
who welcomed me it was david the two
davids deluise um hilarious jkt austin
maria jennifer stone so you're just
close friends with everybody yeah
jennifer's now a nurse i saw her like
she's she left acting she's in she's she
still dabbles in it but she
but she's a nurse
is this is there anything else you could
do like you would do if it wasn't acting
if you weren't an actor what would you
do yeah i think definitely i i would
love i mean i do aside from acting i do
i do real estate like i've been involved
you do you dabbled in what your dad and
your brother would do yeah i've always
liked my dad always said to me like as
soon as you can buy real estate so i did
i realized yeah so you would sell real
estate if you weren't an actor i mean my
plan is to never sell
real estate my plan is to buy it hold it
right and never sell any real estate
right um just because of just it's smart
hold on to it real estate's uh
the best investment you can make for the
most part and so i've always on on i've
always sort of had an entrepreneurial
sort of mindset like a voice anytime i
could invest i invested whether it's um
you know
stocks
um
you know obviously crypto is an asset
class which you know my accountant keeps
telling me hey slow down it's uh he
knows more than me it's vegas money you
know which it is but you know it's
definitely an asset class but yeah i
definitely think on the uh
entrepreneurial side for sure like i've
always wanted to do more than acting i
really want to produce uh but you want
to have your own production company i
saw an interview you were like i want to
have 40 projects
i want to be the rock yeah i want to
have all these projects yeah and you
feel like that's plausible
if i work hard enough yeah
i mean you're still young you're young
enough where you can start doing this
now yeah no i mean i'm already sort of
in the process you know i've been
obtaining ip on books and stuff like
that we've actually pitched a couple
shows to
uh around town over the last
six weeks seven weeks i want you to
remember this face i will when you have
something how can i forget when you have
projects i want you to remember this one
face for 40 projects okay done there's
got to be somewhere where i fit in there
yeah you do
in all of them back to your head
um no yeah so i just and aside from
acting
i have always been very interested in
like forensics
like i've loved like i'd be very
interested to see what a detective would
be like have you ever seen a dead body
never seen a dead body have you ever
smelled a dead body no i don't know it
is the war it's the smell that you don't
forget there was a guy that died in our
building in new york and i walked in and
i go oh my god
that's like sour milk but worse
and my friend was like dude that's a
dead body i'm like no no
and the guy three doors down was
decomposing for like two weeks
and it was seeping through and
i remember my friend dave
he'd knock on the door and he'd say at
the intercom i go hey dave uh the
elevator's broken so you have to take
the stairwell and he goes all right and
he almost died on his way up because i
forced him to take the stairwell up the
stairs and it was just like but it's the
once you smell a dead body you'll never
forget that smell they told me that and
i never forgot if i smelled it again i
know what that was
right i don't know if i could deal with
forensics and all that [ __ ] i know but
if some if no one does then you can't
just get away with killing people so
someone's going to do it yeah
you know like think about that
i mean someone's got to take care of it
someone's got to smell that [ __ ]
someone's going to make sure that the
law is you know so you could get into
that i would definitely uh yeah i could
definitely i could see you as a
detective on like true detective or
something happily do it yeah right
back to kissing selena gomez
um let me let me let's talk about that
for a second i know it's all about
respect and i've i've been there and
i've had to kiss people and you know
talk about respect jesus
good ring time yeah right yeah very nice
you know who that is no
that's uh
or uh electric light orchestra elo oh
blue days
dark nights
[Music]
i'll be uh educating myself and
listening on the way you will
love listen to elo okay their greatest
hits and you will say
this is brilliant all right i think
they're english well
i love that that it makes them brilliant
well
although having an english accent makes
you it makes you do you do sound smarter
i think even without how i just
stuttered and i couldn't get through a
sentence if you're like even having like
an english accent and doing you stutter
and still sound smart yeah i definitely
think sometimes i've got away with it
over here sometimes because what i'm
saying may not necessarily be the most
intelligent thing in the world however
it sounds okay so right right but you
know the respect thing when you're doing
a kissing scene it's just like hey i
want to have you know first of all have
a breath mint don't have a tuna sandwich
before
uh you know before you kiss uh make sure
the person's comfortable
uh
do you but there's also
some come on
sometimes aren't you a little bit like
excited to kiss a certain person as
opposed to sometimes where you're like
oh this is work and then the other thing
is like this is good work
this is i'm getting paid to kiss selena
gomez yeah i think at the time though i
was so
because i think
because i think selena was with
justin at the time oh so that was an
area that i did not want to even like
interfere with uh because i also really
liked him too and he used to come to set
a lot was he really nice really nice i
played hockey with him in a tournament
and he was really nice the first thing
he did was walk up to me and goes hey
how's the girl on smallville was she
cool
lana lange
yeah yeah yeah she really he like really
was enamored by her yeah i liked her we
talked about that yeah he's a big hockey
yeah
yeah um so yeah no i think at the end of
the day
it's
you know
i look everyone's human like of course
like
if there's a beautiful human being like
okay this doesn't suck yeah it doesn't
suck but
with with selena particularly i wasn't
even i wasn't even thinking about it i
was genuinely thinking like
this is
this is her show right like i don't want
to so you didn't even but at the end of
the day did you walk offset in your head
just in like a young how old are you so
uh well because at that point i think i
was like 18 or nine okay so let's see 18
year old walking off set you just kissed
selena gomez wasn't there that kind of
like
those lips were just
fluffy i was wonderful i was very um
what's the word um
i was i wasn't shy when i was 17
but i definitely wasn't extremely
confident
so so you didn't know if she even liked
kissing you
yeah i was just like did she ever say
something like hey good job no really
nice list that was an excellent kiss no
you never did that no i did that once
before where i'm like that was a great
kiss that i felt that that was real that
was that i think we did had it look on
camera
that felt great did you did you did you
or was that okay was my breath all right
i want to know these things you didn't
you never you never went there no i
wanted to keep my job you know i just
always wanted i wanted to get in do my
job get out
you know
that's amazing but she liked you enough
you didn't get fired no and i said so i
said to her a couple of months ago thank
you thank you thank you and we had a
real heart to heart because that show
was
are both of ours you know same for her
like that show brings her back to
before she was selena gomez the pop star
when she was just selena walking down
the street right right
um
so yeah i think it was just a really
special bond that everybody had because
it was the start for everybody could you
go see her in a concert would she give
you free tickets i hope so
i hope so i'll definitely go support her
in a concert though i'd happy i'd be
happy to buy them um but i mean i i have
you seen her before i've never seen her
perform
really no would you like to yeah i think
she's great yeah she i think she's great
she's got a really great voice yeah how
old is she now 20
she's probably 27 26 27 and she's done
with bieber
yeah he's married
he got married yeah bieber's the biebs
married yeah
he's married how was he on set though
lovely was he really loved yeah lovely
just he would go out of his way to just
be nice yeah he was very chill like at
the time it's tough it's tough for any
human being at that level of
of fame i just fame is such a crazy
especially that level of fame you know
how do you comprehend i know people
judge it's so easy to judge somebody
when they're extremely famous you don't
know somebody or it's like oh he walked
by me he didn't smile it's like
ever he walks by every single human for
the rest of his life what he's gonna
just have a permanent grin on his face
forever like he's human yeah he's got to
live his own life too and
i just respect um you know look mistakes
happen i'm sure he'd be the first one to
sort of admit that but his growth is
what i think is really inspiring yeah
you know how much he gives back now what
kind of example he's sending to the
youth because you know it's like today
we live in you know a lot of the world
of influences but he is has a huge
influence on so many people and i think
what he puts out there is really
important and i think he is a great
example right now to young people of to
to spread kindness you know and he's
setting a good example
wow and i really respect that
because for him to find himself during
being whilst being the most famous
person on the planet with unlimited
funds and
unlimited access to anything and anyone
can be dangerous
very dangerous it's dangerous to most
people so i respect i respect what he's
done a lot how much fun did you have
doing runaways
um how much fun it was so cool it was
it's marvel it's you did three seasons
three seasons three seasons why only
three seasons um i think streaming-wise
i think it's i think financially
they that's the cutting you have to
potentially renegotiate with um
everybody
after the third season they don't have
to but i think that it's sort of an
unspoken and you would have killed them
and renegotiated i i uh you would have
said i want so much money it's disney i
don't think anyone kills disney in uh in
negotiations you know
i think you're right i don't think
anybody kills anybody in negotiations
but what was that like i mean it was a
fun character to play really fun
character to play i learned a lot on the
visual effects side of stuff i thought
that was great um
because you always had the dinosaur the
dinosaur right and they had like
animatronics and you had a special
effects team and then they put money
behind it yeah they spent a fortune on
the show also it was a dream of mine to
shoot a paramount i remember when my mom
and dad were because you lived near
there yeah well i live here at 15
minutes but i think i remember when i
first moved to la sitting outside
praying with my mom in the car of like
you know oh i'm going into an audition i
hope i work here one day and then
literally to have a a key code you know
to have the pass but every morning you
then check in and you just drive in and
you say hi to the security guards and
like you see the paramount sign
and you're the first trailers
right there on paramount it's like wait
what is happening here like to remind
myself to pinch myself a lot i had to
remind myself to pinch myself a lot
because it was like wait i dreamed of
this moment you really prayed with your
mom in the car yeah like what do you
mean you closed your eyes yeah and what
did you say did you speak out loud or
did you know silent prayer i'm quite an
internal uh internal prayer
so it was one of those things did you
hold hands
she just kind of closed her eyes you
closed your eyes and you just said what
you needed to say she probably said
something like you know bless my son
he's he's a good kid and he doesn't mean
his body doesn't do any snort yeah and
he doesn't do any below he's a good kid
let him work on this a lot this is a
dream of his yeah whatever that is and
then i'm sure the praying continued once
i got out the car yeah i'm sure she was
praying from then to the end when i came
back right right um
yeah it was just so cool and then josh
schwartz and stephanie savage who wrote
the show right wrote gossip girl
and they were
they were spectacular like they were so
smart i've no
after working with them i understand why
they're so successful um josh's sister
actually lives two doors down from me
which is sort of a weird coincidence now
wow um
but yeah he's great and then jeff loeb
at marvel i love jeff loeb yeah gray he
worked on smallville yeah yeah he was a
writer on smallville he actually texted
me uh yesterday he wants to get dinner
next week which you know it's another
ask jeff if michael rose's mom can come
to dinner okay perfect you should do it
i will just text him i will he'll he'll
say
sure if you want him to i love that no
no he's a great guy that's great see you
dinner all right i'll see you at dinner
um but jeff's great
um and he
you know he believed in me gave me the
opportunity to obviously work in in
marvel but then
at the top
i think jeff was um leaving
and i think a new executive was coming
in it was during the merge you know
buying fox and blah blah blah so um
i think for all marvel shows we were the
last marvel show
uh we were the last marvel television
show the punisher got cancelled and then
we were the last one to stay on because
i think you know as a new executive
comes in
they want a clean slate so i think
that's also what happened i think it was
from a budget point of view but also
from a personal executive point of view
have you ever gone to conventions and
signed autographs yeah so what do you
sign for do you
most of your autographs are for runaways
uh you know what's crazy i feel like
that's why i'm so uh happy
uh and and grateful with just the jobs
because
some people come up to me
for wizards some people come up to me
because i you know i did a few episodes
on pretty little liars yeah this is a
huge show some people come up to me on
faking it which is a really important
show for the lgbtq i a community is it
now ia i believe so i gotta get that
right yeah um and
you know so it was a great opportunity
so it's night and then marvel and and i
haven't obviously been convention since
pretty smart came out um
but but yeah so so do you like
conventions do you like interacting with
fans what's that like for you i really
like it i i love seeing their faces like
up close and personal you know seeing
their like reaction um sometimes the
girls cry girls cry they see you and
they cry they cry yeah and what do you
do you cry back i just no no no i don't
cry back
are you ever touched by a story i'll
tell you and then really right right i
mean i've had people show me that they
have tattoos of my face on them which i
feel like
tattoos of their your face on them where
um
i mean they didn't show me anything else
okay okay good all right but but you
know it's
it's just it's a lot it's a lot and it's
it's amazing but at the same time you
always think
like okay i know it's amazing thank you
so much for being so kind but i'm just
me so there's like a weird
it's hard to show that you're just a
regular guy because you really are a
genuinely good guy
so you want to like make sure they they
know that you're almost trying to prove
yourself like i'm just a regular guy but
at the same time they don't see you as
that yeah exactly so it's kind of this
this dichotomy of like sort of like it's
cool and you're yourself but at the same
time you're this persona you're this
image that they have and you have to do
you feel like you have to live up to
that i think it's important to you know
you're there for a reason which is
people are coming to see you and even if
you're having a bad day you have to make
sure that they have a nice experience
right because
i agree you know like with these people
without your fans you don't have a
career so so it's important to make sure
that they feel loved too because they
give so much love so an actor or singer
or whoever is at the convention can give
some love and time back you know
because they would do anything for you
they'd watch
every show you put out yeah they'd buy
anything that you they'd listen to this
podcast yeah
for sure and it's and and
they're just die-hard fans and so it's
important to make sure that they feel
respected and loved yeah what about
pretty smart how much you enjoying that
the best experience of my life you
really i could tell i saw some
interviews and you just have so much fun
doing that again you have an american
accent yeah you have uh you're and you
have to keep
in perfect shape like i saw the workout
you did before you got here this morning
and i had an anxiety attack because i
thought
i can't do this and also that i felt
like i'm doing things wrong because you
start talking about how you always have
this like uh
you always get the blood going you gotta
you have to have cardio first before you
go into strengthening i just walk down
there and i just kind of lift up weights
and i just kind of do some weights and
then i leave but there's a whole regimen
to it there's a whole mindset right yeah
there's yeah it's and that's your
addiction not the drugs but working out
health consciousness yes yes i think
especially for the show when you've got
a real reason
you know netflix is a huge platform um
and 210 million or subscribers or
something it was insane wow and so you
and i knew that i was going to be
shirtless and so i knew that that tape
was going to last forever and so yeah
you have a real motivation to make sure
you're in the best shape ever you know
but
aside from the show i do live a very
healthy lifestyle you know i eat pretty
well what do you eat like let me take me
through a day just like what will you
have for breakfast i'll probably have
um avocado toast maybe some oatmeal um
i have some you know eggs too
um
and then i'm on a meal plan so you know
for lunch i'll either have a salad or
with chicken in it maybe
chicken eggs um i don't do the sauce
you know because people look at me
they're like eating salad just
because that's where all the bad stuff
comes in it's the sweetness and the
sugary and yeah right but it's kind of
is it kind of bland i love it really i
love it because i just think like yeah
you make your own salads no like
sometimes i'll like go to sweet greens
sweet green has great salads right um
and
or i'll just get it from the from the
meal plan um but then i'll have salmon
or eat um
you know quinoa yeah uh but no candy
bars no
chips
crackers
you really stay away from most of that
if definitely when i'm shooting no sodas
right no are those the things that kill
you i can't i don't i hate soda really i
hate soda i don't i don't really get it
like when people that's so refreshing
and crisp
it's like you take a sip of a diet coke
and it's just like your whole mouth just
explodes yeah then and then like five
minutes later you can feel it oh no i
feel it and i see it
i see it i see it in the gut i see it um
what would you recommend for a 49 year
old who just wants to stay in shape
would you say what would you say get rid
of sodas get rid of the candy and the
sugars and just eat balanced meals and
try to work out a couple days a week is
as simple as that i mean definitely do
some exercise every day you know like
whether it's going for like a brisk walk
for 20 minutes 30 minutes light jog for
15 20 minutes in the morning um yeah and
just stay away from stuff that you
you know that you can avoid so does
sodas are not soda's not good drinking
water is very important
really very important a lot of water
yeah how much water do you drink at that
i mean i it's funny i don't actually
have anything i have in my car but um
it's uh it's a gallon you know you know
one of those water bottles that tell you
exactly like oh 9 a.m you're doing good
yeah 11 a.m keep going i have one of
those and more by the way you know it's
hollywood you go through relationships
you go through breakups you hear it all
the time every actor goes through it are
you mostly friends like for instance
bella thorne i don't know if you want to
talk about that but do you are you still
like
what's the word uh cordial cordial for
sure you are yeah probably more than
cordial because when you go through a
relationship you go through
it depends obviously how it ends and why
it ends um
but you know i think with with bella and
i have just always
just
it was always important to me that she
grew up
to
live out her truth
um and so we come from
very opposite
uh
family dynamics um and so she
unfortunately lost her dad when she was
i think nine wow um and so it was really
important to me that she felt loved and
supported whether or not she was in a
relationship with me or out of a
relationship with me um and so after the
relationship
it was
uh yeah important to me that i was i
always i said it to her so just you know
like i'm
i'm i'm here for you as a as a as a
friend i always will be and i always
will be um
so if someone came up to her and said
hey how was it dating greg sulkin
you think she
does your gut say what did your gut say
you think she'd say
i'd she wouldn't there aren't many
reasons why she would say it was bad
you know right
she i mean nothing's perfect yeah no no
things end most things end yeah she she
would say
yeah i probably love greg it's probably
it's probably what i think you hope she
would say that yeah yeah i hope she
would say it but i think she probably
probably would and how much does
michelle like you talking about her
bringing up her name bella invites us to
her birthday parties every year come on
so michelle and this is
like a fairy tale [ __ ]
life here yeah but i think it was
important it's nice we both all three of
us actually created that dynamic because
it requires a lot of like maturity
maturity yeah you know
me making me explaining to michelle that
like
bella's a person
that
i will always
be there for if she ever needed
something michelle was like extremely
mature and understood that and respected
that and then on on on um
you know on all angles just like i wish
her the best she wishes me the best she
loves michelle i really respect ben who
bella's engaged to now
um so yeah just sort of
you know that's it's hey can't ask for
better there's nothing worse than an ex
hating you yeah there's just no need
there's just no need there's no need for
it especially if no one's done anything
wrong you know if it was just a simple
simple like hey we're just growing we
just didn't work out we're just like
we're not we're not compatible yeah uh
this is called uh [ __ ] talking with greg
sulkin this is just from my patrons you
go to patreon.com inside of you uh these
are people who support the podcast a
little more they ask a few questions
it's rapid fire right that's good little
lisa do you have any hidden talents
hidden talents uh real estate um yeah uh
uh you was a handball champion when i
was a kid you were a handball champion
yeah as a kid i mean me and my partner
but it wasn't just me it was a shared
championship but yeah wow
handball yeah it was like uh we call it
fives in england
fives yeah which is like you playing
like a concrete squash yep yep it's
really cool sport i loved it do you
still play it no no no i'd like to play
would you like to play again sometime
yes
all right yes michelle k what's a
misconception you had about americans or
the u.s in general um
that's a tough one
misconceptions misconceptions
um
you thought they were all vulgar and
rude no no no no no i love this country
they're the best burgers in the world
burgers in the world
burgers in the world i think probably
that i just assumed that the country was
all the same and that over time you
realize that wow this country is huge
and has so many different
um
you know incredible parts to it you know
on southern california but even in the
even in the middle of the country it's
you know there's great places uh dana
asks who have you met that made you goof
out a little bit over
um i think when i was a child
uh
david beckham
and you met him yeah i actually met him
again last week
uh my friends his very close friend's
birthday party um who's also a close
friend of mine and lovely
lovely what actor though are you star
struck over oh actor i haven't met him
but i think i'd like to have a uh a
drink with clooney
really yeah you know what because he's a
gentleman yeah maybe that's why because
you you seem like such a gentleman that
maybe you know
well thank you yeah you know what's
crazy is my classmate on runaways renzi
just did a movie with clooney and so i
was getting all of the information from
like what's he like and my other buddy
graham worked with clooney on uh on a
hulu show so i feel like i've got to be
next like i i've that is my dream to
work with clooney i can't wait to see
you as a bastard
as a boss to play a bastard i'd love to
i really think you'd be great at that
and i think it will surprise everybody
and it will be one of those things where
the headlines are like oh greg sulkin
you know he played all these great nice
guys and now he's just playing you know
he's just a boss he's evil and connect
in the bastard
called the boss there that'll be called
the boston right i don't know if your
mom would like it does she want you to
play those kind of roles that's not so
bad no the bastard's fine oh definitely
yeah but that's acting you know i would
love to play that
so you want a production company you
want to make your own you want to put
your friends in all these projects
projects
what else is there what's up anything
coming up i know you did a horror movie
called don't hang up yes and i haven't
seen that yet but how was it because i
love harum as you can see big horror fan
uh what was your experience on that
i should have i think my lesson
from from that movie was make sure when
you read the script you're looking at
how many
uh nighttime shoots and how many
exteriors and interiors because it's
it's it's wet it's bloody
and it's cold a lot of the time you
either cry a lot cry a lot
did you ever have to have them blow
glycerin in your eyes or whatever to
help you cry i'm sure i think after like
week four yeah [ __ ] it i don't care
because i got to such an emotional low
point that it was just like awful i'm
exhausted calling my dad at the end of
the project and being like that i don't
know if i can do this like that was the
lowest point in acting i think um what
was it about that did you feel like you
were just mentally and physically too
tired to continue yeah i just went to
assume too many dark places that i just
it wasn't enjoyable for me anymore did
that make you sort of deter from doing
horror movies like you wouldn't want to
do one again unless it was no night
shoots not as much crying not as much as
an emotional
voyage
no i think that you just got to be
careful with how many horror movies you
do yeah um so now i'd only do one if it
really made sense right um and also it
it really made me think like oh i want
to do comedy
and i'm a happier human offset when i'm
doing a comedy i'm in a better ma i'm in
a better headspace so
if i could pick and choose um comedy is
definitely something that i'd like to
stick with just for the next little
while and that's why the show is is
amazing because
pretty smart i love netflix people i
love those people yeah it looks like
you're just having a great time and it's
the producers of how i met your mother
yes so i mean it's witty it's smart it's
pretty smart yeah it's pretty small and
you have a great time doing it it
doesn't feel like a job is it in front
of a live studio audience well no
because of covid all right but if we get
a second season then yes it will be so
you really want to do it again yeah
because i've done multicam i did wizards
i did a show called melissa and joey
with jerry lawrence and joan hart who
were so good and such professionals um
love them too and them too those two uh
and
and i did young and hungry too with
emily osmond who i'm working with again
yeah who is
so good at multicam it's absurd
and so i just i don't want this job to
end like i don't want the job to end
because
i'm learning so much i'm having so much
fun doing it i'm working with great
directors um you know pamela freyman
directed us phil lewis who's
unbelievable
um
so yeah i just i don't i do not want it
to end do you get do you you don't seem
like a person who gets really down or
gets anxiety do you ever deal with any
anxiety or depression or anything like
that i don't deal with social anxiety um
i know a few close people to me that do
deal with social anxiety so i always
used to think like
you know i guess i'm i used to be part
of the problem with anxiety in the sense
i didn't really take it seriously i just
thought it was like
oh come on it's fine it's fine but it's
not a mental health is a real thing and
it's so tough because you can't see it
and that's the problem yeah so it's like
you know the brain is so so so complex
then
you know that's why professional
it's tough being an actor i'm sure you
feel like this too but you know you get
messages and it's sometimes dark like
hey i'm thinking of oh yeah not being
here any longer what do i do and i'm
just like hold on like
i seek professional help because
it's i don't i'm not qualified to do
that it's like mental health is a real
thing and so it needs to be taken
seriously so if you do have an issue
try to seek out professional help you
know of course have your friends and
stuff but like
you know it's uh
yeah it's it's it's weird but thankfully
for me
no social anxiety of course i have low
days low moments sure um
you get sad yeah
but it seems like you know
part of your routine part of your
regimen is the fact that you work out a
lot you eat right you're not putting
[ __ ] in your body and that probably
helps a lot yeah that probably does you
know getting the exercise getting the
heart rate up doing all these things
a lot of times you know i feel like when
i'm down i'm depressed i'm anxious it's
because i'm not exercising i'm not
taking care of myself i'm not taking
care of the machine and when you don't
take care of the machine you kind of
fall apart you know things need some
oiling and
lubing
sure is that right sure
man this listen this has been a lot of
fun i was i was a little nervous because
i don't know you
and i and i felt like you know like what
are we going to talk you were so easy to
talk to oh likewise you're really open
and fun and i had a great time today
dude perfect and by the way i'm going to
text jeff you can come i mean you're
welcome to come to dinner text jeff i
will yeah if i'm not working i'd love to
come i love jeff he's a great guy we'll
have a lot we'll have a lot of laughs
uh
thanks for being on here i really
appreciate you allowing me to be inside
of you today thank you i mean that's a
yeah bit weird yeah i say to everybody
not not everybody
well that was a treat he was a treat and
um
you know i don't really feel like we've
had a bad guess yet ryan
would we say if we did um i wouldn't say
it but um
you know uh i i just i really enjoyed
talking to greg he was fun he was it was
good it was fun i always say to you
after the podcast like that's pretty
good yeah and you're like it was great
yeah and i always know it's the ryan
tia's meter
you know you'll be like yeah that means
it was okay sometimes look at me like i
don't know what i'm gonna talk to this
guy about and then an hour and ten
minutes later boom boom you've talked to
this we we've talked uh hey thanks for
listening again please support the
podcast continue to support the podcast
again if you don't know if you didn't
know who greg sulkin was today maybe you
enjoyed it maybe you'll enjoy next week
and there's a list of of
uh guests that we've already had on
our inside eclipse hit 10 million views
so that was really sweet thank you for
uh going on youtube and watching us and
checking out the clips and all the other
fun stuff that we do
check out the inside of you online store
for merch
sunspin.com for a zoom with me and uh
rob or also merch
and uh join patreon to support the
podcast i appreciate all my patrons
we're gonna give a big shout out and
lastly before i give the shout out to
all the the top tier patrons who give a
lot to the podcast
remember if you want to get back
you could give back to echoesofhope.org
to help
the youth um i think there's a there's a
a big problem today with uh you know not
only homeless but
with uh you know teenagers and you know
foster youth trying to get their
lives together and if you go to echoes
of hope.org you can help them out and
foodonfoot.org to help homeless people
out
my good friends at foodonfoot.org tell
them rosenbaum sent you and uh we love
you we're going to give a shout out to
all the top tiers
you hear that
that
those are the gardeners oh yeah i hear
that here we go big shout out to nancy d
leah s trisha f sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e bryan h mama lauren g nico
p jerry w robert b jason w kristin k not
to be confused with kristen crook amelia
oh allison el raj c joshua d emily s cjp
samantha m jennifer and stacy l jen
asked jamal
uh
yeah kimberly e mike e l don sopremo
what up dan 99 more ramirez santiago m
sarah f chad w leanne p janine r maya p
maddie s belinda and chris h dave h
spider-man
spider-man chase sheila g brad uh d-ray
h
yes tabitha t liliana a michelle k
michael s talia m betsy d claire m
laura l chad l rochelle nathan e marion
megkay janelle p travel dan and big
stevie w we're almost done i love these
people angel and ran and see they just
stick with me cory k super sam coleman g
dev nixon michelle a liz i jeremy c
andy t cody r sebastian k gavinator
david c john b brandy d
javore camille s bano or is it bono
we'll never know
v c the c
l c in spanish joey m willie f christina
e adelaide and jeffrey m omar i
lena and design otg eugene and lee
or leah genuinely uh chris p nikki g
cory ktb patricia maria and heather l
and jake b
i couldn't do the show without you guys
top tier patrons who uh if you want to
join patreon and join the family you get
a lot of stuff there's a lot of tears
patreon.com inside of you
uh
yeah
ryan cool are you ready for the holidays
uh i am
you know it's weird this time of year
it's just
i just feel like the year's done and i
just feel like we're just are you sad it
makes me sad somber beginning of
december makes me a little somber it
does because it's all the holidays are
passing us by and then you know you get
to the beginning of next year and it's
just like work work work work work but
you know what we still have a month left
of of the holidays and and you know
christmas spirit and uh
so just you know i will say this ryan
what's the truth it's not over it's not
over yet the holidays aren't over we
still have some time let's try to enjoy
each day
let's try to be grateful for each day
that we have and it's hard but hey we're
here today
we're together you brought me a bottle
of wine i did
do that i'm very happy about it uh you
know had a great podcast today so hey
you know things can always be a lot
worse
so try to stay positive try to stay
happy uh i'm saying that because it's
hard and that's the true meaning of
christmas charlie brown that's a true
meanie christmas hey guys i love you and
thanks for allowing me to be inside of
each and every one of you from myself
michael rosenbaum myself ryan taylor
here in the hollywood hills of
california california we love you and
come back and see us come back and join
us and please continue to support the
podcast thanks guys
[Music]